The end of 2018 couldn’t have been
more stressful: the
protests of the so-called yellow vests have
unleashed a wave of violence and political
rebellion in Emmanuel Macron’s France.
Increasing fuel taxes to reduce its consumption
[and, also, to increase income] has infuriated
a large part of French society.
So, to reject this measure [And to take advantage
and ask for more changes] hundreds of thousands
of people mobilized and took to the streets
wearing yellow vests.
I think we all know what came next: thousands
of arrests, hundreds wounded and a government
held against the ropes, forced to take a step
back.
But, just a second, because in this video
we’re going to talk about China, not France.
Then why the hell are we talking about the
yellow vests?
No, folks, I haven’t lost my mind.
France’s incident may have led to a more
violent result than expected, but it isn’t
an unusual one.
When a society doesn’t feel represented
by its politicians or believes that their
rights as citizens are being violated, protests
and demonstrations are commonplace.
However, this doesn’t happen in China.
Which leads to a few questions:
Why do we never see protests like this in
China?
Don’t the Chinese have more than enough
reasons to feel dissatisfied?
And perhaps the key question, how does the
Chinese government manage to keep 1.3 billion
people under control and all without any sign
of discontent?
Okay, some of you may be thinking, “obviously,
it's a dictatorship.”
Yes, you’re right, but that doesn’t tell
the whole story.
As you know, there’s always more to it.
Listen up.
(THE CHINESE NON-CHANGE)
Despite the reforms, of which we’ve already
spoken here on VisualPolitik, 20 or 30 years
ago it was expected that today’s China would
be very different.
Many experts predicted that as the Chinese
economy began to prosper and its middle class
to grow, within a short time social demands
would cause a change in the political system
towards a more open, free, transparent and
less corrupt system.
Since then, the country has experienced an
impressive economic takeoff and the Chinese
middle class is now composed of hundreds of
millions of people...
But still there’s no trace of riots.
Ok, there have been protests, but there’s
no comparison... and for many Chinese people,
seeing a demonstration is like seeing someone
drinking Carling beer: you know it happens,
but it’s weird to see it for yourself.
And not only that, but with Xi Jinping in
power the exact opposite is happening.
While Chinese society is experiencing its
best moment in history in economic terms,
Xi Jinping is the most powerful president
since Mao.
In fact he won’t even respect the two-mandate
limitation that Chinese leaders had to adhere
to.
Yup, another case like that of Evo Morales
in Bolivia
But... let's go back to the question at hand,
Why does the Chinese government have so much
control over everything that happens?
Why hasn’t this control suffered any erosion
despite the fact that now the country is much
richer and much more open to the world?
What can we expect in the future?
Folks, these are the 3 key questions we’re
going to answer in this video.
And yes, we’ll talk about the repression
machine later... but we can also find some
additional elements.
Check it out.
(THE PACT)
A recent New York Times article talked about
how the Chinese government has managed to
turn their economic development into a way
to legitimize the regime.
And that has a lot to do with a kind of tacit
pact that exists between the Chinese government
and a good portion of Chinese society.
An agreement based on the following:
the government promises to do what it can
to achieve better living conditions, and in
return society, or at least a good part of
it, doesn’t question the government itself
and looks the other way on political issues.
Here’s a question-- controversial but very
topical: would you be willing to renounce
civil liberties and political participation
in exchange for an improvement in your standard
of living?
Leave your answer in the comments and also
in this survey.
But, just a second.
This is all very easy to say... but not as
easy to carry out.
So the question we can ask ourselves is, how
on earth has the Chinese government managed
to fulfill its part of the bargain?
Well, we’ve already talked about one of
the issues on VisualPolitik, in a video we
made about the reforms this country carried
out after Mao’s death.
To create wealth, the Chinese government put
aside economic Marxism and freed the forces
of private enterprise, competition, globalization
and capitalism.
Yes, we’ve already told you this, but...
that’s not all.
The other element that the government has
used has been none other than education.
And not only because they control the content,
which we all know.
See, to make everyone feel like they had a
chance, especially the almost 40% of the rural
population that’s still mostly poor – and
this amounts to more than 500 million people
in the part of China that doesn’t have Shanghai’s
skyscrapers – the Chinese government has
created a social narrative by which anyone
who strives, regardless of their economic
level, can climb the ladder of social mobility
and reach the highest echelons.
How did they do that?
Well, through universities and an access system
known as Gaokao.
The Gaokao is a very hard test that, if you
pass it, guarantees the opportunity to study
at a higher education institution regardless
of your income level or your family's situation.
Because in China, unless you have money, access
isn’t universal, far from it.
Each year 9 million young people compete for
only tens of thousands of places.
And most young people know that University
can change their life.
You can already imagine the incredible amount
of competition that exists to pass this exam.
But in a country where corruption in institutions
is usually part of the game, Gaokao is seen
as an opportunity, a relatively fair test
that any student can access.
That way, the narrative that the Chinese government
has built for years is that in this country
there’s full social mobility, any young
person regardless of their family’s income
level can progress up the social scale.
And if they don’t achieve that progress,
it’s their fault.
(AUDIO: “Gaokao allows the government to
say: ‘If you are not successful, you can
only blame yourself.
You did not work hard enough [...] That is
a very powerful way of governing.”
- Yong Zhao, an education professor at the
University of Kansas.)
Actually it really isn’t like that, the
Gaokao is a system that favors some skills
over others, and therefore some students over
others.
But the Chinese government has managed to
introduce this interpretation of equality
into society.
That’s how the Chinese government has kept
Chinese society relatively satisfied over
the past few years.
The Chinese have seen how their lives improve
year after year and thanks to the Gaokao and
a university system that allows for social
mobility, everyone feels like opportunities
are available to everyone.
In addition, the Gaokao favors a study model
based on memory and repetition and not on
creativity and critical analysis.
But we’ll talk about that some other time.
But that’s not all.
Let's continue.
(TIME PERSPECTIVE)
The second question that might explain why
the country’s economic growth hasn’t been
accompanied by political demands has a lot
to do with the speed of the changes.
Allow me to explain, social and cultural changes
often happen much more slowly than economic
and technological changes.
Yes, China has experienced a huge amount of
development but not enough time has passed
for political demands to emerge.
This isn’t strange.
If we take a look at the history of Western
democracies, both in Europe and even in America,
we can see that political changes have always
been much slower than economic changes.
Although they did arrive eventually.
But we can’t forget that countries such
as Spain, Portugal, Taiwan, South Korea and
the nations of Eastern Europe, among many
others, suffered under dictatorships of all
kinds until only a few decades ago.
In other words, the Chinese are still moving
from poverty to a more comfortable lifestyle.
But yes, it’s obvious that we can’t talk
about the Chinese government’s control over
its citizens without discussing coercion.
Listen up.
(THE POWER OF THE FORCE)
I think none of us will be surprised if I
say that the Chinese government has more than
enough tools to subdue protests.
At the end of the day China is still a dictatorship
that leads in rankings like these:
(AUDIO: “China named 'world’s top executioner'
as global rate falls.
Amnesty says more people executed in China
than rest of world combined.”
- The Guardian)
(AUDIO: "China is ‘the world’s biggest
prison for journalists".
- Reporters Without Borders)
Folks, the Chinese government’s control
is so great that as you all know they’ve
basically been able to create their own Internet.
In China, this network is so censored that
services like Google, YouTube and Facebook
as well as millions of web pages are blocked.
Except for the use of VPN networks – which
are of course illegal – the Chinese only
see the information that the Chinese government
allows them to see.
And there’s more.
It seems that by 2020 the Chinese government
wants to implement a kind of ranking that
will classify each and every Chinese citizen
based on a lot of variables: credit, financial,
social, political, legal, etc., etc.
That is, the Chinese government wants to create
a ranking of good and bad citizens.
Have you seen Black Mirror?
(AUDIO: “Black Mirror is almost a reality:
China says it's on track to launch its dystopian
scorecard system that ranks citizens on every
aspect of their behaviour by 2020”.
- Daily Mirror)
(AUDIO: “It will affect eligibility for
loans, jobs, even where your children go to
school [...] For example, citizens with low
scores will not be hired by certain employers
and will be forbidden from obtaining some
jobs, including in the civil service, journalism
and legal fields, where of course you must
be deemed trustworthy”.
- Rachel Botsman, author of Who Can You Trust?)
Obviously, political issues will carry a great
deal of weight, so being critical of the Beijing
government could place you among the most
unreliable citizens, which would close most
doors, both personal and professional, for
you.
Terrifying, right?
Well, now you can see the tools that the Chinese
government employs to maintain its control
over society.
First, The political pact and the promise
of prosperity and opportunity for all; Second,
The fact that social change moves more slowly
than economic change; and Third, the huge
amount of control and repression that the
Chinese government uses are all reasons why
there are no yellow vests in China.
But the question we can all ask ourselves
is, will the Chinese government perpetuate
its model or is this country going to suffer
a wave of democratic change and openness?
Leave your answer in the comments.
So I really hope you enjoyed this video, please
hit like if you did, and don’t forget to
subscribe for brand new videos.
Don’t forget to check out our friends at
the Reconsider Media Podcast - they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not mine.
Also, this channel is possible because of
Patreon, and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting
our mission of providing independent political
coverage.
And as always, I’ll see you in the next
video.